worst day ah this is a classic went out
with a girl called Ruth right and we
went on four or five dates all going
well and yeah I was I was about to meet
some of her friends she was going to
meet some of my friends was we just been
on dates just the two of us and my mates
arrived and I said to Ruth oh look my
mates are arriving guys guys this is
Ruth and she went it's June for like
three weeks I've been courting the dog
name I mean that's a classic but yeah
that one didn't last too long anyway
yeah anyway we got married okay so I
went on my first tinder date this is bad
this is bad the guy kept getting up to
go to the bathroom
so I thought oh maybe he's on drugs or
he has diarrhea I'm like what's
happening I start scrolling you know you
check in on tinder you could see when
they're active he was active on tinder
in the bathroom as he was on the date
with me that's all oh that's bad Julie
no I had such little respect for myself
at that time that I stayed yeah and I
got wasted with him
oh by far I went on one tinder date
around four and a half years ago I was
with some buddies we were in Mexico so
we're coming I'm all jealous cuz they're
like talking to like Mexican chicks on
tinder like a real you know we're like
oh well let's meet up with them so I'm I
make a profile I start talking with this
lady San Diego right so I get there I'm
waiting at the bar restaurant for her
and in walks this woman who looks
vaguely like the woman that was in the
pictures she took those pictures maybe
15 to 18 years ago and at one point she
she she had the audacity to ask me after
we had a couple of drinks do I look like
I do in my photos Oh Ana sad well she no
she didn't and so I was like yeah and
whatever you you know answer with that
really high pitch you know it's a total
lie and so like I'm really uncomfortable
I start drinking too much I'm obviously
not gonna drive back from San Diego to
LA at this point so she invited me to
stay the night at her place and I fell
asleep on her couch with her two pugs
one by my one by my ear here and one
just like along my torso area guarding
me totally guarding me and that was by
far the worst dating experience I could
answer
I need this guy and he asked me out and
we go out and we go out a couple times
where maybe I'm like our third date he
also ran into a parked car on our first
date
oh he also got arrested on one of our
dates this is not even the bad day right
and and yet you continue to go out with
him okay um very nice guy by the way and
we go out we get drunk there you go I
used to get drunk uh and I'm like you
know what come back to my dorm just
sleep here like you don't drive yeah cuz
I'm good about that it's 5:00 in the
morning we go to sleep so I'm in bunk
beds cuz this is a dorm right so we're
up on the top bunk and my roommate is
right here and I wake up at 6:00 in the
morning about an hour later to my
roommates screaming and the guy on the
floor it turns out he had tried to get
out of bed and like because we were up
he like fell and hit a lamp which woke
her up by hitting her in the face so
that's how she woke up and we're like
hey are you okay
and he doesn't respond and he walks over
to the closet and he puts his hand on
her closet we have those open closets
and he takes out his and he pees all
over her clothes and yoga mat and she
runs out screaming he leaves she's like
what he leaves girl and I like I'm like
I wash everything like washing her yoga
mat in the communal showers and then we
and then I get a call later from him and
he's like hey nunu told me to get out
and like the you know don't come he'll
kill you but like what happened Oh me
and no memory to this day has no memory
of it we dated for two years this is
sweetie pie hi you know who you are
oh my god
you